pour le monde d'après j'ai choisi de
parler de l'abstention puisque ça va
être l'un connu également de l'élection
présidentielle et alors il y a le groupe
korian vous savez ce groupe d'ehpad qui
accueille les personnes âgées qui a une
solution et qu'ils proposent est bien de
faire des bureaux de vote au sein de ces
établissements alors c'est incroyable
puisque là on a un groupe privé vous
savez que c'est les communes qui
organise les élections et on ne met pas
des bureaux de vote n'importe où et bien
là vous avez l'énarque à la tête du
groupe korian qui travaillent avec les
pouvoirs publics et qui dit voilà comme
nous résidents ne peuvent pas se
déplacer alors bien sûr avant on faisait
des procurations il y avait un sport et
ça sue c'est d'avoir le plus de
population possible en fonction
d'établissements mais les questions à la
fois de recenser les habitants départ
des habitants d pad et ceux qui sont
inscrits sur les listes électorales ou
non de faire de la formation citoyenne
c'est à dire de parler un peu de
politique avec ces gens là donc
j'aimerais savoir qui va leur parler de
politique et comment et ensuite de les
faire voter au sein de l'établissement
est parti pour être une bonne chose
c'était bien fait c'est à dire qu'on
aille chercher des électeurs puisque
l'abstention est une plaie de 2,7 selon
ainsi pour le moment et que si c'était
fait de manière mixte sous la houlette
des communes ça pourrait être valable
que de manière non bien sûr au fond de
son lit puissent voter sans avoir à
sauter ça pour être bien fait si la
personne à sa tête si la personne c'est
pour qu'ils aient le vote s'il n'y a pas
de trafic d'influencé ou de quelque
sorte et si effectivement il ya un
contrôle de ces urnes là on rentre dans
un espèce de délire c'est d'ailleurs un
gérald darmanin qui parlait de vote à
distance un pas de vote par
correspondance donc on voit bien qu'ils
sont en train de phosphorer sur des
solutions pour avoir une façon de voter
en dehors des bureaux de vote peut-être
parce que le pass and i ter sera
toujours là peut-être parce qu'on ne
pourra mème pas à sortir on sera
peut-être confinés par un nouveau
variant ultra ultra criminelle et
mortels je ne sais pas donc on voit bien
qu'ils réfléchissent à des façons de
contourner ce suffrage universel où on
va voter dans des bureaux de vote et ça
quand même c'est une première de dire
qu'un groupe privé organiserait un
scrutin moi ça m'inquiète au plus haut
[Musique]